What do you think about intravenous vitamin C and baking soda intravenously?
We found a clinic in Arizona that does that for cancer.
Intervenous vitamin C, yes, baking soda intravenous, I don't know about that. No.
You have to see, understand, you have a buffering system in your body.
You know people that, oh, I just need to alkalize myself. I just need to alkalize myself.
I just need to get out, you know, but yeah, no, it doesn't work that way.
If your blood varies very much off of, I think, the pH of 7.345 or something like that for blood,
you'll die. So your body will buffer it. So if you could somehow alkalize your blood,
your body would have to be working very hard to acidify it, to balance out the pH,
or you'll just die. So no, vitamin C, IV, yes, that could be a very good benefit for cancer.
You could do intravenous vitamin C, you know, you don't have to go away to a clinic,
just every large city has IV centers that you could do a vitamin C, IV locally.
Plus you need to do that on a very regular basis once or twice a week for it to be effective.